when it comes to deciding what to do
with our lives
we are frequently presented with what
looks like a very painful choice
the passionate path versus the safe path
the latter involves the slow mastery of
a dependable profession
we will be bored but we know we'll never
be fired
meanwhile the former is a high wire act
in which we fantasize generating an
income from what we deeply love
and yet we constantly fear penury and
humiliation
the choice can feel acute but it may be
less so than it seems once we properly
explore the concept of safety
we are never properly safe so long as we
are doing something we hate or are
pursuing out of cowardice
in the deeply competitive conditions of
modernity
our backup career the one we adopt out
of fear
will be someone else's central ambition
our plan b will be someone else's plan a
which places us at an immediate
disadvantage in terms of the energy and
focus we are able to muster
the safe choice might ruin us
by contrast what we love is what we are
obsessed by anyway we do it for free
which decisively increases our chances
of mastery while reducing the price of
failure
a decade of mixed results on a passion
project is inherently less onerous than
unspectacular returns for a whole career
in a hateful field
it is in the end not very safe to use
the one life we have forcing ourselves
to do what we know from the outset we
won't enjoy
simply in order to keep living
this isn't safety it's masochism
we may all have to spend our first two
decades suffering through the education
system but at some point we are allowed
to leave school
at some point we need to have a shot at
answering what life could be about
beyond obedience and timidity
it's not very common to have a passion
most of us don't
yet if we are blessed enough to have one
we are risking far more than we should
by failing to heed its call
for more from the school of life
you can subscribe to our channel and
take a look at our range of products on
our website
you